YOU HAVE GONE SO FAR LEFT THAT
YOU HAVE LEFT AMERICA.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
LAST NIGHT IT WAS MY GREAT
VILLAGE TO SPEAK WITH ROBERT
MICKENS AND ELIZABETH ALVARADO,
THEY WERE GUESTS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT TUESDAY'S
STATE OF THE UNION.
AS ARE MY NEXT GUESTS EVELYN
RODRIGUEZ AND FREDDY CUEVAS,
THEY ARE THE PARENTS OF A
16-YEAR-OLD WHO WAS ALSO KILLED
BY MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
I WANT TO SAY I KNOW IT'S VERY
MAKES ME THINK OF WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOUR DAUGHTER JUST TWO YEARS
AGO BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
SO MUCH.
TO START WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE HEARD THE SENTIMENT
EXPRESSED TIME AND AGAIN THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING TOO
MUCH OF THIS MS-13 ISSUE.
IT'S BEING USED FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES AND PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT MS-13 UNLESS IT WAS
FROM FOX NEWS, DISMISSING IT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> IT'S A SITUATION THAT IS ALL
OVER, WE NEED TO FIND A SOLUTION
IN ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THIS.
IT IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND I
DON'T WANT ANOTHER FAMILY TO GO
THROUGH THE PAIN THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ENDURING EVERY DAY SINCE
THIS HAPPENED.
>> Laura: FOR OUR VIEWERS THAT
DON'T KNOW THE BRUTALITY OF
MS-13, TELL US WHAT HAPPENED TO
BEST FRIEND TO GO INTO SEEING A
FRIEND.
WHATEVER SITUATION THAT THEY HAD
WHICH WAS VERY MINOR.
THEY WENT OVER THERE, THEY MADE
THEIR PEACE ON THE WAY BACK,
THAT'S WHEN THE SITUATION
OCCURRED.
THINGS WENT WRONG.
THEY WERE ALREADY IN THE
PARKING LOT AND THEY WERE
HANGING OUT IN THE PARKING LOT.
UNFORTUNATELY MY DAUGHTER AND
BOUNDARIES OF LORETTO PARK.
THEY HAPPENED TO COME ACROSS THE
CONTROVERSY.
>> Laura: THE MOTTO OF MS-13
IS KILL, RAPE, AND CONTROL.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER AND MY HEART
BREAKS IT TO READ WHAT THEY DID
WHO FOUND THEM SAID THEY HAD NOT
EVER SEEN SUCH BRUTALITY.
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
YOU WERE THERE AT THE STATE OF
THE UNION, THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO STOOD AND APPLAUDED
FOR THE COURAGE, AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO SAT ON THEIR HANDS
SCOWLING, WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THEM TONIGHT, THOSE WHO WOULD
NOT STAND TO HONOR YOUR DAUGHTER
NOT STAND TO HONOR YOUR DAUGHTE
DAUGHTER?
WHO STOOD UP AND BELIEVED IN
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
THINKING.
I KNOW AS A PARENT, I FEEL IT
EVERY DAY.
THERE'S NOT A SECOND BUT I DON'T
THINK ABOUT MY DAUGHTER.
OF A PARENT LOSING THEIR CHILD
TO THIS GANG VIOLENCE.
I HOPE THEY NEVER WILL, IT'S
SOMETHING YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT,
LIVES ARE AHEAD OF THEM.
I WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE CHOICES AND THE
SOLUTIONS IN ROUTE TO TAKE CARE
OF THIS PROBLEM, IT'S A SERIOUS
PROBLEM THEY NEED TO REALLY
CONSIDER IT.
I KNOW THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES
BASIS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY WHO FEAR
DEPORTATION.
I'M SURE THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
FEAR.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO ON THIS SHOW
IS A SHOWCASE THOSE WHO ARE
FORGOTTEN.
UNTIL PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME
ALONG, I THINK THEY WERE LARGELY
IGNORED AND INVISIBLE VICTIMS.
WE THINK THE EMPATHY IT SHOULD
GO TO AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO ARE
BRUTALLY HURT AND HARMED AND
KILLED BY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERY NIGHT AND WE SALUTE YOU
FOR COMING ON.
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS, YOU'RE
COMMUNITY, LIKE I SAID THIS IS
NOT JUST HAPPENING HERE.
FREDDIE WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,